[Music]
you're getting married and how are you
feeling about everything
I feel good my fiance is awesome and
she's uh you know working the wedding
planning now and and but but I know I
never thought I was gonna have kids but
she's like let's have kids and I was
like that sounds like a great idea which
is a good sign when you're about to
marry someone right and but I'm very
nervous about having kids what were you
guys you both have kids
I can't you're in their mid 50s I have a
12 year old daughter and a 10 year old
son and yeah it's amazing it's it's
fantastic great I just like it's strange
when you you never really talk about sex
with your family with your parents until
you start to get married and then
they're like when you're gonna start
giving us some grandkids come on you
should try for some grandkids and I
always feel like that's like the in-laws
going when are you gonna start finishing
inside our daughter like it's so creepy
I don't know why are we talking about
those the cleaner part is not what
they're saying
when they're gonna sing the fact that
it's coming king when you're gonna place
your seat in our dawdles fertile womb
they're gonna know music and they're
wearing later whoo boom Bob based the
seed base the seed whoa Wow okay didn't
you have that with your in-laws or like
something it actually my in-laws right
away my father-in-law right away was
like grandchildren grandchildren
grandchildren before we even I mean
months before when you like I'm working
on it yeah I went nothing works down
there you hear people say that your
whole life and it isn't until you're
married that you start to actually put
together the mechanics of it and what
like you said what that really means and
it's like why don't you just stay out of
our nether region out of that I remember
the I you know I didn't talk right my
parents are pretty open about stuff but
I actually remember the moment I learned
where babies come from or my from my
parents I was four years old and I kind
of had that for I was four that's way
too young it's not it's not like they
were like you're old enough you know
like it was it was just I I had that
existential crisis that a four-year-old
has where you kind of go I was not
before and now I am and how did that
happen so my parents were in the car my
dad was driving momma's and I was in the
backseat I didn't know where I go where
do babies come from and my dad was like
I'll field this one well then have a
penis and ladies have a vagina and a man
puts his penis in a vagina while later a
baby comes out I was like okay follow up
questions how does the man put his penis
and my mom goes I'll field this one and
then very slowly she turned to looking
sideways at my father she goes not very
far yeah
so they divorce a divorce and you're the
reason your therapist that you were but
you were oh wait a minute do you think
you're gonna do a better job explaining
when you have a child and your child is
maybe a little older than four are you
gonna do a better job no because I'm you
know I'm a spazzy comic and and I really
can I just I'm awkward around kids and I
word things in weird ways I know if my
kids like where do babies come from I'll
be like oh wow
poop okay um oh say here you go you like
ice cream cones right uh-huh well would
you enjoy an ice cream cone if someone
stretched a balloon over it that's where
babies come from yeah you shouldn't have
any talk at all with your trial no no my
wife is of the variety that she's very
clinical about everything you know she's
very I mean she's telling them about you
like the uterine lining when they're 2
and what do you know II mean and how do
what do you say do you say Jesus forbid
we shall not have this discussion in
this house
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you